shut up
thank you
here's me explaining why the argument
saying men invented everything is stupid
and shouldn't be said on International
Women's Day Men invented that phone
you're on that house you're living in
the app you're using
did you watch the video or men invented
everything
okay uh why
what tell me why men have invented most
things
because women are stupid I haven't got a
brain
only straw
okay is it that or is it the fact that
we've been oppressed for centuries
weren't allowed to go to college until
the 60s get an education well that's
still severely underrepresented in stem
Majors where all the inventions are from
people want to talk about that you want
to talk about the fact that the women
who did invent things had their ideas
stolen because those men like other
things on their body have teeny tiny
videos on that one here now we're going
down the alternate history
no actually did you know the cotton gin
was invented by a lady but they covered
it all up it was really secret ladies
invented everything you know a woman
invented the automobile but they covered
it up
who them they did Bill Gates after that
little chicken deck and also
separate note
women didn't really invent anything but
they didn't invent it because they were
oppressed
which which they weren't but let's say
that they let's say that they were
well how'd they get oppressed wouldn't
that be a knock against the feminist if
the women could be oppressed then
wouldn't that be another Mark in the
in the column for the men now of course
the feminist framing is just totally
wrong anyway
because the relation between the Sexes
is not
primarily antagonistic it's a
relationship of love and complementarity
which the women have forgotten since the
1960s when the feminists ruined
everything and then the feminists sent
this alternative history which is that
women
had awful terrible lives before
conveniently right before the time that
you're like Boomer great aunt you know
started hanging around Berkeley and then
all of a sudden everything got bright
and Rosy but if you if you look at at
Women's reported happiness for instance
both objectively and relative to men
they've declined in both cases since the
1960s so feminism has failed in
everything
[Music]
because it's a false anthropology and
it's made women much worse off than they
were before feminism if it wasn't for
the suffragettes I probably wouldn't be
standing here now I'd be in a kitchen
where I belong so they've got a retcon
everything and rewrite history and and
try to make these these incoherent
mutually contradictory Arguments for for
why things were so bad on the one hand
men really didn't even everything but
it's because they oppressed the women on
the other hand women actually invented
all this stuff but it was all just
written out by the men in the Illuminati
and I don't know the Freemasons maybe
okay Stitch this if you have a subtle
feminist power move that you do on the
regular okay disregard the noises I'm
making pasta
um I do this constantly I've been doing
it for years it actually bothers my
boyfriend whenever we go out because
he doesn't understand why I do it until
I explain it to him
I never move out of the way
I will let a man walk into me before I
move
because they are so used to just like
not interrupting their time and just to
proceed forward and keep moving until
they're in my line and I just keep
walking I've been like shoulder checked
I've been everything but I'm like if
you're not moving I'm not moving yeah I
like that that's good haven't moved for
a man in years I kind of like that
actually I don't that's not a feminist
move necessarily maybe there's an
overlap here but that's just an
old-fashioned move like if I'm in in
public
and there's a woman coming where I'm
coming I I will step out of the way
always you always let a woman enter the
room before you you always let a woman
onto a rid of an elevator before you
always pull the chair forward and you
always have the woman go first that's
that's called chivalry that's called
being a gentleman your parents must be
very proud so what she's saying is some
men are a gentlemanly today and so I'm
not going to get out of their way that's
good actually that's a good whether
she's doing it for feminist reasons or
whatever it's good to remind men that
they need to act like gentlemen
[Applause]
women tell me I'm beautiful I will
usually reply with I know
it worked so well so well because then
I'll go
again
what did you want me to say you say
thank you when you receive a compliment
do you just want to tell me
am I supposed to not know
I don't know what
are we not both in on that
it's great I love it yeah but being rude
and Vain and prideful is not attractive
the woman who looks fine I'm not going
to comment hundred looks
if one were to compliment that woman if
one were to be attracted to that woman
one would find her immediately less
attractive when she behaves in a way
that is uh boastful and prideful and
ugly it's ugly behavior and so it makes
an otherwise attractive woman less
attractive so what I do is I refuse to
look down when I'm passing a guy or a
girl but when I'm walking in the
hallways of work or when I'm walking the
trails or if I'm out for a jog anything
like that my eyes stay up you'll catch
yourself wanting to walk past somebody
like this
you know just kind of like lowering your
gaze being submissive and I refuse and
it's a strong move and sometimes I'll
even say
in my head when I walk past just so that
I give myself the confidence to walk
past without lowering my eyes you should
try it great oh I'm very supportive of
that this was something I noticed in
Italy the looking down especially when
it's a man walking by a woman the
looking away or looking down that's very
American I think it's maybe Anglo more
broadly the Italians don't do that the
Italians you walk by a woman you stare
right at her and they're a little bit
more forward as a people something about
that Mediterranean sun and I like that
that's a nice power move and I like what
she says she walks away she goes hey
yeah okay it's very it's not just that's
not feminist at all in fact I find that
kind of coquettish
I'm into it I have two
the first one is that whenever I'm
addressing an envelope to a couple I
always put the woman's name before the
man's name just put a pause right there
who is the head of household
is it the man or the woman the husband
or the wife what's their last name does
the woman take the husband's last name
as is traditional sometimes today
they'll keep the woman will keep her
father's name so you still have two
men's names there but the one looking
for father's name and then they seem as
though they're not married they're not
one family or sometimes people will
hyphenate that's popular now too you're
a hyphenit someone's name is
gonna go first so does it make more
sense for the woman to be the head of
the household or for the man to be the
head of the household what do you think
what do most women want
I bet more women want the man to be the
head of the household then men want to
be the head of the household because
women
like it when a man is strong men usually
if we were really left to our own
Brothers we would sit on the couch
eating potato chips watching TV doing
not we wouldn't make decisions we
wouldn't lead we wouldn't take on stress
we wouldn't work very hard and feel we
have to pay the bills but we do it
because we're called to do that we feel
that's our duty and I think the women
like that they don't want some soy boy
beta they want a guy who's actually
going to do his job so in that situation
who's going to be the head of the
household is it going to be the man he's
going to be resting his his head on the
woman's shoulder he's gonna say oh honey
go kill the spider for me please honey
well how to do
and then the wife has to go kill the
spider no I don't think so
everybody wants the husband to be the
head of the family because man is the
head of the family naturally well if the
man's ahead of the family then you
should put the man's name first and
frankly you shouldn't put the woman's
name on the letter period you should
write the letter to Mr and Mrs Michael
Knowles now let's see how it looks so
far
you have come together you've left your
families of birth
and you are coming together and becoming
one flesh what God is joined let no man
separate not only do you put the man's
name first that's the name you put
period
[Music]
I can't understand a word of it keep
going as an elementary school music
teacher sometimes in the classroom I'll
need like chairs or tables moved and so
I always ask I need strong students to
move this for me and I always pick 50 or
more of those students girls because
girls are strong yeah and you know when
I go and I pick the football team at
recess I always pick the kids who don't
have any legs yeah I do just to make a
point when I pick people to carry the
heavy stuff around the classroom I
always pick the physically weakest
people to humiliate them and mock them
into upend reality that's good for
anybody right no I don't think it is I
think it's about as good for for society
as feminism has been which is to say
not fairy see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]